Okay you good? Yeah
I'm gonna do this one to you alright
Alright so I wanna do one called ‘Forget About Money’
Really the idea behind this is people
when they think about the economy
they very often tend to think about it in terms of
money and it stops them from
really understanding how the economy works
and understanding that really
the economy is about real things
real resources, real people doing real work
and I call this
like money obsession, or money centrism and
you see this everywhere
and it's not just from ordinary people
you also see this from economists
so a good example of this is
when we had the 2008 financial crisis
that led to a massive upward redistribution of wealth
and how did we deal with it?
Slashing interest rates to zero
which is monetary policy doing something with money
printing money and quantitative easing, again
monetary policy, printing money.
Covid, massive economic crisis
massive upward redistribution of wealth
what did we do?
Slash rates to zero, quantitative easing
print money, so really... and you know
these are the economists that run our our countries
they run our economies when there are crises
even crises
that involve massive redistribution of real resources
they focus on money centric solutions
and they totally ignore what has happened
with real resources
and then you know
we can obviously see now that the way that
those two crises were managed
has led to falling living standards
and I've been aware of this for a long time
and I've been critical of this for a long time
and I've been arguing about
this for a long time
but when I argue with people about this
very often, regardless of whether they are on the right
or the left
or the centre of the political economic spectrum
whatever you like, they tend to say: ‘No
the problem is not real resources
the problem is money’
so I always remember
I did this Masters at Oxford 2017 to 2019
and you’re with a lot of like classic
classic economists
you know modern elite trained economists
and you know, I was saying, you know
the problem is massive upward redistribution of wealth
you know wealth is being lost by governments
and the middle class is, same stuff I always say
and this guy said no
no no
the problem is just that
we didn't cut interest rates far enough
this is a nice guy by the way
like I would consider him a friend
you know he's not an idiot
he's a smart guy
classically trained elite economist
and I'm like, ‘dude like we cut interest rates to zero!’
He's like, ‘no
we should have cut interest rates to minus three %’
and it's like
his criticism is we just didn't cut rates
far down enough and I don't know if you ever saw
the interview I did with the IEA
so the IEA for those who don't know is
it's a very right wing economic think tank
and I went and did an interview
on their channel years ago
when I was a lot less well known
it's worth watching to be honest quite funny
and I went on there against, is it Mark Littlewood?
What is his name?
And he was very respectful but
he came out and this is quite funny
when you consider the story I just told
he said the problem is
we shouldn't have cut interest rates to zero
we should have kept them at 3, 4%
so, and you know, at the time I was there
it was quite funny because we could
we could already see at the time
that interest rates were gonna come back up
because it was, this was like
when inflation was starting to come through
and I was like, ‘dude
you're telling me you think if rates go back to 3
4% that's gonna fix the problem?’
and he was like yeah and I was like
‘well you are gonna see very shortly
that that is not gonna fix the problem’, basically
but I think this is really interesting right
that you have this economic context in which
every problem is dealt with
by fiddling around with money, printing money
giving out money
printing out money and that clearly doesn't work
you know in the aftermath of 2008
I talk about this a lot
that cutting rates to zero was considered a super
unusual, extreme, emergency policy
and everybody
thought it would have this really powerful
economic rebound effect, same in Covid
by the way
so everybody thought these massive moves
in money would have these massive real effects
and they just didn't have the effects
that were predicted, right
so even though we are now, we're like 15 years on
more than 15 years on from 2008
the lesson
and in a context of academic economists
basically being fixated on
the way to fix every problem is money
the last 17 years should really have shown us
economists have overestimated
the power of money
specifically and monetary policy
that should be obvious and yet even within that context
the main criticisms of the policy are that
are not that there was an
excessive focus on monetary policy
but on the one side, rates should have been cut further
and on the other side, rates shouldn't have been cut
there's money centrism from the establishment
which is failing
and there is money centrism from the critics
on both sides of the political spectrum
like it's just an absolute inability
to view the f***ing real resources
and all the time that that is happening
that the sense that the establishment
and the left and the right are all fixating on money
that wealth distribution is just going out of control
so you'll see like
money money money money money money money money money
money money money money money
no one is looking at real resources
and at the same time
government wealth is f***ing collapsing
so you're just like losing
you're losing your real resources
and all you're talking about is money
money money
money and
I'm gonna wind in here like
because I'm trying to get more medieval history
into this, let's put like some bits here
so if you wanna skip the medieval history part
there was this...
there was this, so there's this idea in like
Abrahamic religion. Christianity
Judaism, Islam
it's one of the 10 Commandments
you should not worship graven images
and it led to this
which means you shouldn't worship images of god
and it led to this like
big discussion of whether you should
be allowed to make a statue of god
or draw a picture of god
and this is why to this day in Islam
you can't have a picture of god
and there were wars in Greece
in the 8th century and 9th century
people are killing each other
over whether you should have a picture of god
and it was because you know
people worried that if you make a picture of God
people will confuse it for actual God
and I think what you're seeing here is people
have confused money for real resources
and I think I think we live in an age where like
money is kind of the new religion
and people confuse money for real resources
and this is like
this confusion really prevents people from seeing
you know
seeing the forest in front of their eyes basically
because all they think about is money
they don't think about real resources
so you see these amazing things happen
which is monetary policy fails to deal with the crisis
real resource distribution collapses
nobody notices the best example of this is Covid
so Covid, we knew
and obviously I’ve talked about this a million times
we knew
the government was gonna give a trillion pounds out
which it did, trillion pounds, f***ng lot of money right
20 grand per person, US numbers even bigger, and
when that happens, when you know
tons of money is given out
and there's been no change in
what's happened to real resources
you should know distribution is gonna change
probably inflation crisis
probably a big increase in asset prices
it should be obvious right
cause you printed tons of money
you haven't done anything to real resources
but what was the media actually saying
the media was saying, ‘oh my God
people have got so much money now
we're gonna have such an economic boom when we reopen’
like how idiotic is that?
But this is like
it's like, you must have had this conversation
when you were a kid at some point where
where you or somebody says hey
like why don't we just make more money?
Why don't we just print more money?
Give everybody more money
why don't we just do that?
Or there's this US film called
Idiocracy where
is it Terry Crews that like really hench Black actor
you know the guy?
And he tried to become president and he's like
we're gonna be billionaires, and he's just like
we're just gonna give everyone a billion dollars
and it's like
it's basically what we did during Covid right
we print all this money, we give all this money out
nothing could have been more obvious than
that was gonna be an inflation crisis
and a massive increase in asset prices
and I made tons of money betting on these things
and I spoke about these things happening
and yet the media narrative at the time was
we’re just gonna have an economic boom
because everybody's got so much money
and that is again
just like this really idiotic money obsession
and it always reminds me of this
understanding that they had in medieval Europe
which is if you make too many
if you make pictures of God
people are gonna confuse it for actual God, you know
money is not and I've said it before
money is not real resources
but this confusion between money and real resources
causes so
many problems and
it's connected to the current
I believe
quite naive Labour economic policy of just build build
build, grow grow grow
and this idea is kind of based... and
they're even trying to do things like
they're trying to convince
ordinary people to not hold their savings in cash
but to buy stocks and shares
and they think it's gonna grow the economy, like it's...
I can't explain to you how idiotic this is, right
if you think that the only thing that matters is money
then what you see is oh my God
people that just have money sitting in their accounts
it's just being wasted, like
let's get them to invest the money
and the economy is gonna grow, right
money is just a system, it's a spreadsheet
like, it balances
it has... some people are in credit
some people are in debt
it has to balance out. If people wanna know about that
we can we can put in the description
our videos on money and our videos on debt
so you can understand that, like obviously
when the government printed and gave out money
people would accumulate money
that doesn't mean that you can just
suddenly have a load of investment
because if you want actual investment
what you need is to build more real resources, okay?
it's not just about money
People might have money sitting in their accounts
but there are no unused real resources, okay?
We don't live in a world now where there's like
a million guys who are unemployed
and there’s like a huge like land out there.
Like there are times in history
where you kind of have unused resources
the best example probably is like the US
the European colonization of
of the US okay
so obviously there were Native Americans in the US
but the Native Americans were like basically driven out
they were like, there was a basically a genocide
they were all killed
and then you end up with like almost this empty land
empty land, and then you have
you know a lot of unemployed Europeans
and then it's, okay, we take the unemployed people
we send them to America
they expand into this infinite land
and you can just grow and grow and grow
when you have these unused resources
you can just grow like this
but the truth is we don't have
you know, we don't have like unused resources
we don't have loads of people who
don't have jobs, you know
all of the resources are used, right?
If you want, for example
to have more houses
then you need to take those resources
from somewhere else
we don't just have a ton of builders
and a ton of building materials
just sitting by the side of the road
to build the houses right
you need to deal with the question
of the distribution of real resources
and you see this all the time
we get people in the comments saying
oh ‘Gary Gary
Gary, you're talking about zero sum fallacy
we can always make more resources’. Okay...
how? Because at the moment everything is being used, okay?
If you want to build more resources
that's fine, somebody is going to have to consume
less for you to be able to do that building
because the resources have to come from somewhere
those builders that you need to build the houses
they are currently making f***ing kitchen extensions
and renovations for rich people's houses, okay?
So you need to somehow get the resources from them
you see what I'm saying
the obsession with money
leads to an Assumption that there are...
that we can just do things like building new housing
or growing the economy
without taking anything away from somebody
which you just f***ing can't because, obviously from the...
and it's, it's this
small minded attempt to extend
the economy of the individual
to the country which is
if I am here
and I have half a million pounds or whatever
say I've got £2 million in my account
I can buy a plot of land and all the resources
and I can build a house
and what that is doing is I'm taking resources
I'm outbidding somebody else for those resources
so from the perspective of an individual
I have money I can build
I can create a thing, fine
in a society
where all of the resources are already used
you cannot simply grow that economy
build those houses
without taking those resources from somebody else
and what I am saying is
in an economy where you have this tiny group of people
who increasingly own all of the resources
all of the assets and have unbelievably
enormous amounts of luxury spending
we should be reducing their consumption
so we can grow the economy
and there's no other way to do it
there's no other way to do it, listen
in the short term it is a zero sum economy
you cannot suddenly grow the economy
you need to devote resources to growing the economy
and those resources need to come from somewhere
you do need to deal with the competitive nature
and I think it's this money
centrism that allows people to forget
that the world is being used
there's no, you know, you cannot go into the wild
and f***ing chop down the trees
and build your own f***ing house anymore
like everything is owned, everything is owned
you cannot grow the economy
without getting the resources
from the guys who own the resources
the people who own the resources are the f***ing rich
either you tax the rich, or you don't get the growth
and you have this, you know
these very naive policies which is like
we're just gonna grow, we're gonna grow
we're gonna borrow from the rich
and we're just gonna grow
you know
but the rich are only gonna lend to you at profit
so they are gonna take the growth
you know the growth is all gonna be for them you know
either you deal with this distribution
or you don't get the growth
so, to conclude the video
money centrism gives the illusion
that we can grow at no cost to anybody
it is not true, we exist in a world of real resources
what really matters is the real resources
I would encourage people to go down the street
look at the buildings
look at the high streets, understand real resources
real people doing real jobs
making real things
and the distribution of those things matters
At the moment
real resources are being aggressively transferred
away from the middle class
and the working class
and the government towards the super rich
that will lead to a loss in the consumption
of the middle class
of the working class and of government services
assets are not sitting on the sidelines
assets are not money. What matters is real resources
what matters is real distribution
If you do not focus on
protecting your share of the distribution
I guarantee you
the people who have passive income of 1 million
£2 million a week will increase their share
over time, your share will decrease
money is not the only thing that matters
you need to protect your share of real resources
thank you.